Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Elisabeth Buffard
A comienzos del 1905,
el joven a punto de cumplir 26 años,
Albert Einstein,
se enfrentaba a la vida
como académico fracasado.
La mayoría de los físicos de la época
se habían burlado de la idea
de que este pequeño funcionario
pudiera aportar mucho a la ciencia.
Sin embargo, en el año siguiente,
Einstein publicaría no uno,
no dos,
no tres,
sino cuatro trabajos extraordinarios,
cada uno en un tema diferente,
destinados a transformar radicalmente
nuestra comprensión del universo.
El mito de que Einstein había fracasado
en matemáticas es sólo un mito.
Él dominó el cálculo por su cuenta ya a
los 15 años y obtuvo buenos resultados
tanto en su escuela secundaria de Múnich
como en la politécnica de Suiza,
donde estudió para lograr el diploma
para enseñar matemáticas y física.
Pero saltarse las clases para pasar
más tiempo en el laboratorio
y no mostrar la debida deferencia
a sus profesores
descarriló su carrera prevista.
No le consideraron ni siquiera
para un puesto de asistente de laboratorio,
tuvo que conformarse con un trabajo
en la oficina de patentes suiza,
obtenido con la ayuda
del padre de un amigo.
Aún trabajando seis días a la semana
como un empleado de patentes,
Einstein se las arregló para sacar
algo de tiempo para la física,
discutir el último trabajo
con amigos cercanos,
y publicar un par de trabajos menores.
Fue una gran sorpresa
cuando en marzo de 1905,
se presentó un documento
con una hipótesis sorprendente.
A pesar de décadas de evidencia
de que la luz era una onda,
Einstein propuso que podría
tratarse de una partícula,
mostrando que fenómenos misteriosos,
tales como el efecto fotoeléctrico,
podrían explicarse mediante su hipótesis.
La idea fue ridiculizada
en los siguientes años,
pero Einstein estaba simplemente
20 años por delante de su tiempo.
La dualidad onda-partícula
fue candidata a convertirse
en la piedra angular
de la revolución cuántica.
Dos meses después, en mayo,
Einstein presentó un segundo documento,
esta vez abordando la centenaria pregunta
de si realmente existen los átomos.
Aunque ciertas teorías se construyeron
bajo la idea de los átomos invisibles,
algunos científicos prominentes
todavía creían que eran una ficción útil,
más que objetos físicos reales.
Pero Einstein utilizó
un argumento ingenioso,
demostrando que el comportamiento
de las partículas pequeñas
que se mueven al azar
alrededor en un líquido,
conocido como movimiento browniano,
se podría predecir con precisión
debido a las colisiones de millones
de átomos invisibles.
Los experimentos pronto
confirmaron el modelo de Einstein,
y los escépticos atómicos
tiraron la toalla.
El tercer documento llegó en junio.
Durante mucho tiempo, Einstein había
tenido problemas por una inconsistencia
entre dos principios
fundamentales de la física.
El principio bien establecido
de la relatividad,
que inició su andadura con Galileo,
afirmaba que el movimiento
absoluto no podía definirse.
Sin embargo, la teoría electromagnética,
también bien establecida,
afirmó que existía
el movimiento absoluto.
La discrepancia y
la incapacidad para resolverlo,
dejó a Einstein en lo que describió
como un estado de tensión psíquica.
Pero un día de mayo, tras haber
reflexionado sobre el rompecabezas
con su amigo Michele Besso,
empezó a ver la luz.
Einstein se dio cuenta de que
la contradicción se podría resolver
si la velocidad de la luz es lo que
se mantiene constante,
independientemente del
marco de referencia,
mientras que el tiempo y el espacio
son relativos al observador.
A Einstein le tomo solo unas semanas
trabajar en los detalles
y formular lo que llegó conocerse
como la relatividad especial.
La teoría no sólo destrozó nuestro
entendimiento previo de la realidad,
sino también allanaría el camino
para que las tecnologías,
que van desde los aceleradores de partículas,
hasta el sistema de posicionamiento global.
Uno podría pensar que esto
era suficiente, pero en septiembre
llegó el cuarto artículo como
seguimiento
al artículo de la relatividad especial.
Einstein había reflexionado
algo más acerca de su teoría,
y se dio cuenta que también
implicaba que la masa y la energía,
una aparentemente sólida y
la otra supuestamente etérea,
eran en realidad equivalentes.
Y su relación podría expresarse
en lo que se convertiría en la más famosa
y consecuente ecuación de la historia:
E=mc².
Einstein no se convertiría en un icono
conocido mundialmente
hasta después de casi otros 15 años.
Fue solo tras confirmar su teoría general
de la relatividad en 1919
midiendo la curvatura de la luz
de las estrellas durante un eclipse solar
que la prensa lo convertiría
en una celebridad.
Pero incluso si hubiera desaparecido
de nuevo
en la oficina de patentes y
no hubiera logrado nada más tras 1905,
esos cuatro documentos
de su año milagroso
habría seguido siendo el estándar
de oro del genio sorprendente inesperado.